rabbani ist das anders das einfach
anfangen ich habe schon so oft in meinem
leben fest vorgenommen dass ich nicht
mehr auf hilfe reagiere allerdings
werden meine die ems voll gesperrt von
euch mit videos auf die ich reagieren
soll
und heute reagieren wir auf dieses video
in das baby ist nur eine plastikpuppe
ja
da ist man ja schon wieder dass ein nur
schwachsinn der wann dieses ziel scheint
ihr kommen übrigens am ersten 12
der bischof von de aber heute soll es
nicht um ein tolles match gehen sondern
um hilf mir von euch würde ich sagen ich
klick direkt auf play
die kinder waren wurde angefahren mein
gott was habe ich getan
also man muss auf jeden fall direkt zu
beginn dass man sagen die
schauspielkünste sind wieder 18 jetzt
kommt noch eine dritte person an
jetzt kommt eine ältere dame oder dazu
die sagt ich kann helfen ich bin
krankenschwester ist das denn jetzt
schon die plastikpuppe die sieger in der
hand hält der arme opa alter der bisher
von allen angemeckert krieg das halbem
herzen fakt und schlussendlich ist es
eigentlich nur eine plastikpuppe oder
ist es nur eine plastikpuppe ich weiß
nicht wie man das baby noch gar nicht so
richtig gesehen jetzt checken die leute
das ist gar kein richtiges baby ist
mit der problematik aber nicht
es ist wirklich eine plastikpuppe wie am
arsch kammern sein ich weiß sie wissen
es mittlerweile schon aber ich möchte
trotzdem mit jeder hilft mir action von
mir sagen wenn ich hier irgendwie immer
irgendwas lach oder keine ahnung was
dann soll es um gottes willen nicht
persönlich beleidigen oder attackierend
den schauspielern hinter den rollen
gegenüber gemeint sein sondern lediglich
die gespielte rolle betreffen oder wenn
ich irgendwas sagen soll es nicht gegen
linda gehen oder gegen ihre plastikpuppe
okay jetzt sagt wie sollen sie in ruhe
lassen und jetzt packt ihre sachen und
geht doch auch vorhin im kerstin hat
kein verständnis für die 32 jährige soll
doch ein verständnis geworben
heja länder also ich kann mich voll
verstehen wenn meine plastikpuppe
kaputtgehen würde dann würde ich auch
wein dass wir mit diesem kinderwagen und
diese puppe die josephine trinken
ok
sie denkt dass das tatsächlich ihr sohn
ist
noch krasser am arsch sich zu beginn
gedacht haben uns hier gut geht es ein
kleines finden egal ist mir ja ja dass
wir es mit einer fehlgeburt zu tun
nicht die hintergründe das ist nur das
was diese friseurinnen kollegin keine
ahnung was da gesagt hat aber die linde
hatte anscheinend eine fehlgeburt und
dann könnte ich irgendwo verstehen dass
sie sich nach einem baby sehen und das
in der plastikpuppe dann wieder erkennt
aber ich würde sagen wir schauen mal
weiter das ist wie gesagt alles nur
geschauspielert
ich will jetzt gar nicht drüber reden
kommt aber in den laden rein und erzählt
dass und sie will es recht nicht vor
ihrem kind darüber reden was
schlussendlich nur eine plastikpuppe ist
ja ich kann das schon ganz verstehen es
ist sinnlos bilden
ich will nicht reden und schon gar nicht
von kind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe das ist der film
das ist das kind von mir und der länder
und ja finden willst auch was dazu sagen
der luca shop ist scheiße ab mit dem
wieder nicht schublade nach dem
autounfall braucht länger unbedingt
einen neuen kinderwagen für ihr baby
denn verfilmt ist der 32 jährigen das
beste gerade gut genug
ab wann kann ich vor damals getragen auf
schulter und die kauft sich da so ein
alcantara wagen mit der zeitung für kind
und wahrscheinlich auch noch navi und
netflix integriert ledermontur ist sehr
gut da können sie im wald auf
verschiedenen boden ja 499 ist
o
100 er wird den kleinen avenida gerne
doch dem kinderheim bitteschön
ok also die frau schaut jetzt nach
bettwäsche während linda reinlegt und
jetzt kommt wahrscheinlich die frau
gleich wieder mit der bettwäsche und
denkt sich so wie meine tochter hat auch
er seinen sohn bekommen was das konto
ist auch ein geschenk für sie da sind
ein anderer tv immer gucken da hab ich
das baby mal so was habe ich in meinem
ganzen leben liebt die kosten in eine
puppe in diesen klassen ist kein spaß
hier ganz kurz ich bin so ein bisschen
auf der seite von länder
was ist denn wenn dann ein zehnjähriges
mädchen mit der puppe rein kommt und
sagt hey ich hätte gerne neuen wagen für
meine puppe als ob dann der verkäuferin
sagt das ist ja keinen spaß ich verkauft
die dänen nicht wie will den ordner
verkauft ist auch egal für welchen zweck
linda kind fiel
wer aber real talk ich weiß nicht ob ich
mich da wieder zu weiteren staiger war
klar das ist natürlich alles nur
gespielt aber ich versuche es ja immer
auch so ein bisschen auf einer anderen
ebene zu betrachten
versteht ihr was ich meine und darf den
anderen den rücken stärken hinter du
bist nicht komplett am rad abgetreten
habe ich schon kraft wollen sie was
verkaufen oder wollen sie nichts
verkaufen weinreben gern gekauft ja dann
kann ich ihnen gerne für den verkauf
fertig machen geld bisschen mehr alles
geregelt
ich habe andere besondere alter
deutscher sprache das ist glaube ich
oder einfach sie haben ganze zeit schon
schwickert sind einfach ihre haare
das ist ja klar wer die haare wie du
möchtest aber nicht so ganz mein typ
eine überraschung
wir haben vermischt und nur zweimal die
haben verhütet und nur zweimal ja dann
wartet mal ab bis zu finden sie ist mein
lieber freund jason kingsley der 5 sie
ist schon bewusst dass eine puppe ist
jetzt zu mir ich liebe ihn und uns gibt
es nur im doppelpack im text richtig
habe ich es eine freundin die gerade aus
der klasse ausgaben
[Musik]
scheiße zu lachen ich meine leute es ist
alles geschauspielert und blabla und
dies dass und ananas und äpfel früchte
sind allgemein tolle gegenstände aber
real top wie gerade schon gesagt ich
glaube das ist wirklich solche arten von
traumatisierung geben könnte deswegen
fühle ich mich dann schlecht darüber zu
lachen
obwohl's vollständige schauspielers und
es ist hilf mir und es ist eine frau die
denkt ihre plastikpuppe werden echtes
echter lebender mensch aber ja ich
wir schauen weiter die g8 und kadetten
kommt die mutter sowie acht grüne neune
[Applaus]
aber kannst du mich jetzt wo ich mutter
bin und den kleinsten habe ich andere
pflichten ein anderes zu tun
wie wäre es denn wenn du finden einfach
mal ein bisschen hinlegt auf die decke
da kann ein bisschen spiel und wir
unterhalten uns habe ich in der küche
ja er finde er spielt dann ein bisschen
auf der auf der decke
das war nur aufpassen dass er nicht
abhebt ich gehe mal kurz das niveau
suchen okay
die junge bands auftraten um dem thema
ja kein spielzeug
bitte vorsichtig josefin der film er ist
kein spielzeug
also wie ist es auch so hier heißt ja
auch will ich auch ganz vorsichtig mit
umgehen ist ja auch kein spielzeug de
also real talk der finne der bedeutet
mir echt ne menge also da bin ich
wirklich extrem vorsichtig wo man
manchmal geht es einfach mit mir durch
denn was soll was zu sagen dreckiger und
schmeißt aus dem fenster an der stelle
ich das heute wieder das allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
meine reaktion hierauf diese hilfe
folgen das baby ist nur eine
plastikpuppe gefallen hat würde ich mich
sehr sehr toll dabei einen daumen hoch
von euch unter dem video hier freund
schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare was
ihr allgemein davon haltet also was
heißt davon haltet also ich glaube
niemand von uns so richtig hatte das
schon mal so eine traumatisierung falls
doch schreibt mir dazu gern ich will
mich hier wirklich in keinster weise
darüber lustig machen oder sonst
irgendwie was natürlich klar hierbei
hilft mir wird alles noch mal ein
bisschen überspitzt dargestellt und dann
zusammen mit der schlechten
schauspielleistung ist es natürlich
lustig und da kommt noch ab und zu ein
lachen raus aber viel und ich würde
sagen tschüss moniert gerne einen kanal
falls noch kein teil von der lupus ist
dieses gemüse
[Musik]